hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new iphone 12
mini and today we're not only gonna
compare it against the iphone 12
see how much smaller is it really and
how much more comfortable in the hand
is it but we're also gonna compare it to
the other small
iphone the iphone s e and see
how big of a difference do we have we'll
also compare the performance we're going
to take a look at the displays and see
how much of a difference does oled
really make we're going to compare the
speakers
touch id against face id and much more
let's go ahead and open up the mini and
i
on purpose didn't even look at these at
the apple store because i
wanted to have an honest first reaction
okay let's get this thing out i'm gonna
peel this off right away
okay wow okay so it's heavier than i
thought
i thought it'd be a bigger difference i
didn't look up the specs side by side
but
this thing is so mini when you put it up
next to the 12
that's when you really notice it it's
really weird that size wise
it seems like a toy it is so small but
the feel in the hand
and the weight makes it feel really
premium
and honestly holding in my hands right
now the 12 mini
feels heavier than the 12. now i know
that's not true at least i'm guessing so
i'll have angelica put up the weights
right here but it's just because it's so
compact and it's so much crammed into
such a small device
it feels a lot more dense now before i
compare all of the exterior differences
with the 12 and se
let's talk about chargers obviously you
guys probably know
the new phones don't come with chargers
but in fact the iphone se no longer
comes with a five wall brick
either so you're gonna have to buy
charger if you don't already have one
now apple would be happy to sell you
theirs for 19
but we would suggest anchors because
look how much smaller this thing
is and it puts out the same 20 watts now
inker's not a channel sponsor
yet but i would still suggest this
because it's not only is it
cheaper but with that if you're going to
be charging your phone with
magsafe it actually charges faster we
actually did an ultimate charger
comparison that you guys should check
out
after this video now that we're
mentioning mac safe
i do want to say that the 12 mini does
not accept the full
15 watt peak charging it actually is
limited to 12
watts now this is where it gets a little
bit interesting
the 12 will accept the peak 15 watts but
not for very long not a lot of people
talk about this
it actually goes down to six watts after
it starts heating up a little bit
so what i'm really interested to find
out is if the 12 mini
will go even lower than that and that is
something that we're going to cover in
our review
of the 12 mini we'll make sure you get
that info to you guys so make sure you
guys hit that subscribe button and help
us get to 500
000 subscribers before 2021. now i have
to say that even though i was majorly
disappointed in magsafe in my ultimate
charger test
i'm still enjoying using it there's
something very satisfying about it
clicking on like that and then you hear
that little chime come up
and you can use it like this as long as
you don't need fast charging it is nice
and on top of that
last few days i've been testing out the
magsafe wallet with my iphone
12 pro and i liked it a lot more than i
thought i would based on different
videos
so let's go ahead and put it on look at
that
it fits perfectly it's like it was made
for the iphone 12 mini wow okay
gripping this thing in the hand that
feels incredible it felt good on my
iphone
12 pro it kind of filled in the way your
hand holds but it feels
amazing here and the fact that it
actually matches up
the edges to the edges perfectly it just
feels so natural and with that
look at that it doesn't pop off anywhere
near as easily
as on the other phones because it
matches up perfectly you're gripping the
whole thing at the same time
and you can't just easily rotate it and
get it off so
if you're somebody that wants to use the
wallet you want a minimalist
kind of design and size this is
perfect and it feels so good in the hand
and of course with the se
it is not going to work because we don't
have any magsafe magnets now let's
compare the design differences and i
want to start off with
the colors obviously this blue pops like
crazy and i'm not typically a fan of
blue but
i love this one and unfortunately i have
to say for the 12 mini i have the
product red
i am not really a fan if we put it side
by side
with the se which is also product red
you guys will see
how less rich of a red this is some
people call it salmon
i don't know i'm seeing pink i like the
deep
darker red of the product red model if
we take a look at
the the frame here it is lighter
it still looks like red on the mini at
least on the sides but man i really wish
they stuck with this color i also have
to say that i love the new
camera bump they're etching into this
glass it makes it look
very premium way better than the
old-school way of just having a little
lens
with the little ring around it now it's
interesting that the camera bumps are
the same between the 12 and 12 mini
everything's identical
but the apple logo is actually smaller
let's go ahead and stack these up
next to each other and this is probably
the biggest difference i've seen
so far usually phones are fairly similar
the 12
is taller but also quite a bit wider the
difference is pretty substantial
so what does that mean for comfort in
the hand well the 12 feels comfortable
you have a really nice grip
because of the flat edges let's try out
the 12
mini and it definitely feels
smaller in the hand but comfort wise
it's not as big of a difference as i
expected that's very interesting let's
grab the se
all right the se is more comfortable
honestly because of these rounded edges
it just feels a little bit softer
against your palm
and it's weird it feels quite a bit
thinner because of the raptor's edges as
well
and technically it's 7.3 millimeters
compared to 7.4
but it feels quite a bit thinner let's
go ahead and stack these two
up next to each other and wow so the se
even though it's really small it's still
taller and wider than the new mini
so that's very weird to see i wasn't
expected to have as big of a difference
and putting him in the hand you honestly
can't
feel as much of a difference as you see
visually
and as far as the frame and the buttons
the 12 minis and the 12's button
is much larger and it's really clicky it
feels really nice
whereas the sc has this really small one
it's not mushy
but it's definitely not as nice feeling
and then on the opposite side of course
we have the volume buttons that are
slightly
larger our sim tray actually moved as
well
and on the 12 and 12 mini we have this
5g antenna
on the side and we're going to talk
about 5g and data speeds in general in
just a bit
and now switch to the front so you guys
can see a massive difference the iphone
12 has a larger screen
at 6.1 inches the mini is a 5.4 inch
screen
and then the sc has a 4.7 now the mini
is a lot smaller than the se
but the screen is much larger fills in
the whole phone which is nice you don't
have that
big chin and forehead and i have to say
that it feels weird holding the se and
seeing those
massive you know forehead and bezel it
just feels so much nicer with the full
screen
now with that we have a difference in
design all the new iphones have a
straight
flat edge so the screen is completely
flat and then it meets the frame
whereas the se it curves over the side
and we have a little plastic insert that
you probably can't see
but you feel the difference between the
glass the plastic and then the metal
frame
and the new designs definitely feel more
premium of course with the mini
we have this notch cutting into the
display
that's because we have face id there and
let's go ahead and do a quick test
face id versus touch id we just press
down
pretty quick you can actually do it all
in one step just by pressing down
and you're there whereas with face id
you either have to
raise it and then it's going to turn on
the screen and then swipe up
or you can tap on the screen and swipe
up and as far as speed
i mean they're both very quick it's hard
to tell a difference
and for convenience i love face id and
times where you don't have a mask
you if you're wearing gloves it still
works whereas if you're wearing a mask
touch id is definitely nice
now you might think that the face id
sensors are smaller because everything's
smaller
and that's actually not true if we put
them side by side like this
the whole notch is identical in size
but because the screen is smaller all of
the icons have to be
cramped in there and they're quite a bit
smaller as well
now one thing that almost nobody knows
about is that the bezel on the 12 mini
is actually the thinnest bezel out of
all of the
new iphones the pros the pro max they're
able to slim it down just a little
bit and let's compare the display panels
themselves the brightness the quality
the 12 mini is identical to the 12 pro
other than size so i'm going to scoot
this
over and we're going to compare lcd
versus oled
i'm surprised that i can actually tell a
difference in terms of clarity or
sharpness
the icons and the text look more crisp
on the 12 mini
than the se which still has a retina
display that's because the 12 mini
actually has the most detailed screen in
terms of pixels
print out of any of the iphones now the
next thing i want to take a look at
is the shift in brightness we have lcd
versus oled
and if we look from the side the se gets
much darker if we're not watching
perfectly
just facing us whereas the oled screen
doesn't have any issues
and the good thing is the new 12s they
have the best oled screens that don't
turn blue from the side and now let's
compare the brightness both are set to
manual brightness
okay very interesting the new one does
look brighter but not by
that much and that's because the 12 and
the 12 mini
their displays their oled displays are
limited to 650 nits
which is similar to a really good lcd
display
like the one we have in the se the pro
models those can actually get brighter
now we also have a difference in terms
of hdr
so these oled screens they can actually
get up to 1200 nits
if it needs it okay this is interesting
we're setting up to compare hdr
and i just updated the youtube app and
not only does the sc now play back in
hdr but it also allows 4k60 playback
now as you can see the se actually has a
larger video
if we're not zooming in on the iphone 12
mini
now right away i see a massive
difference
the iphone 12 mini looks like hdr we
have nice contrast
it actually is sharper even though the
video streaming is the same
and the brights just pop so much
not only that but in the darker scenes
we have a lot of contrast blacks are
pure black
because of the oled screen instead of
kind of gray
and man even the colors they're a little
bit more saturated they pop a little bit
more
the 12 minute gives you an hdr viewing
experience now
if we want to fill up the whole screen
you are going to cut out a part of your
image
so some of the parts get cut out that
does give you a little bit more of an
immersive experience without the huge
chin and forehead but we do have that
notch cutting into it
overall the iphone sc hdr video doesn't
look like hdr it looks like just an
option where the button comes up whereas
a 12 minute video looks great
with that said if you watch a lot of
videos the iphone 12
gives you a much larger display it's
definitely noticeable and it is more
immersive
because of that larger screen now as far
as actual quality
i can't really tell a difference if i
look close in this shot right there the
building
it actually looks a little bit sharper
with the finer detail probably because
of the extra pixel density
but it is almost identical and now it's
time for our speaker
comparison i have to say i'm expecting
the 12 mini to absolutely smoke the se
because there's been so many generations
of changes and i guess it'll be cool to
see how big of a difference
there really is but what i'm most
curious about is how it stacks up
compared to the regular
12. this phone is much larger so are we
still going to get the newer
nicer loud speakers or do they have to
downgrade them so i'm going to go ahead
and split this up into two
separate speaker comparisons so we can
tell the actual difference
go ahead and put on your best pair of
headphones or the only pair of
headphones you have
and let's take a listen
[Music]
where we started you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section
below which one sounds better and why
now i have to say that i was a little
bit wrong i was expecting a bigger
difference
now there are definitely some clear
differences some that you guys may not
be able to hear because
we're recording through a mono mic and
going you know through youtube
but uh the bass surprisingly was
basically the same
mids were a little bit richer on the 12
minutes same thing with the highs
they're a little bit more crisp and
sharp
just like the rest of the new phones now
where i noticed the biggest difference
was the stereo sound listening to the se
a lot of the sound majorities coming
from the bottom speaker and the earpiece
speakers fling it in a little bit
whereas the 12 mini sounds perfectly
balanced
much more immersive now along with that
as far as the peak volume this is
actually the same i use my apple watch
to test and both of them peaked at the
same exact 81
decibels that's pretty close to the
phone so no differences
in volume now the next thing that i'm
curious about is how
the 12 mini compares to the regular 12
so let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
once again let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section
and i have to say yes my speculations
were correct the regular 12 is
louder than the 12 mini and it
definitely sounds
better the 12 mini it doesn't sound bad
it sounds nice and balanced
but the mids and the bass in the 12 my
goodness it is a big
jump much deeper much richer the high
frequencies are basically the same
and then we do get a little bit more
loudness as well so with the larger
phone you do
get better speakers and if you watch a
lot of movies without headphones
it's gonna help and now let's get into
performance starting off
with data speeds as you may know apple
is
really pushing 5g on all of the new
iphones
and not to say it actually does matter
even if you don't have 5g in your city
now what's very unique about this year
is that for the first time ever
all of the iphones the 12 the 12 pro the
pro max in the mini
have the same exact antennas with the
iphone
se you actually had a worse antenna and
modem
than the iphone 11 pros the se actually
has two by two antennas instead of four
by four
so you would take a hit in speeds and
reception now
with the newer phones we actually did a
bunch of testing already here's some
shots from our previous test
and the new 12s are so much faster as
far as internet speeds
even if you don't have 5g in your city
the standard lte is much faster
that is also because we're using
snapdragon modems now and even the 12
mini the cheapest one has the very best
x55 snapdragon modem and if you look at
some other android phones
for the cheaper smaller phones you'll
get worse quality reception
and speeds in the last few weeks i've
seen a massive difference both in terms
of speeds and reception
and that's comparing uh 12 pro against
my 11 pro max
which has even better antennas than the
se so if you guys want to see a real
world comparison
go and check the video that i made that
also includes
tethering if you use that and now let's
compare the processor and graphics
performance i have geekbench 5 opened up
here
and we're going to go ahead and run the
cpu test one thing you'll notice
is that we do have a difference in ram
the iphone se has three gigs of ram just
like the previous
iphone 11 whereas the 12 mini and the 12
they have four gigs of ram
like the older 11 pros so how much of a
difference does that make in their real
world
well i don't think it's a big difference
as far as app
loading with these newer phones there's
a lot more processing going on
especially if you're taking photos and
videos
and you really need the extra ram in
some cases you'll have background apps
that could close
to make sure you have enough kind of ram
for that task
whereas with the se the cameras which
we'll talk about in just a bit
the whole processing is much lower much
less intensive
so as far as ram i don't think that's
gonna make a big difference and we have
our scores and i have to say
that this is the closest scoring i've
ever seen between the mini
and the regular 12. they're almost
identical
we're slightly under 1600 for single
core slightly over 4 000 for multi-core
so these don't get as high of a score
as the pro models do i'm not sure why
maybe because the pros have
extra ram and with the se it is still a
shockingly good score so the difference
is about 20
both in single core and in multi core
and i also have to say that
for 400 bucks man you're getting some
killer performance this thing's going to
beat out all the android phones on the
market
even like the 1400 ones and now let's go
ahead and take a look at
graphics performance i'm gonna run
geekbenches
metal test and here are the scores
it looks like the mini actually has the
best score which was surprising i
thought maybe because of thermals it'd
be lower
but they are pretty close to the regular
12 and the se
that is once again a really excellent
score so we're seeing that the minis
close to 30 percent better graphics
performance in terms of metal
and uh the se with the latest ios 14
it actually jumped up by quite a bit in
terms of performance
now another difference that you're not
seeing here is the new neural core
the neural engine with the new a14
bionic
that has a massive improvement in
yesterday's video we actually did a
video editing test including some dolby
vision
footage and that actually showed a
really good result
between the 813 and the a14 processor so
make sure you guys go and check out that
comparison
if you haven't seen that yet and now
let's talk about the biggest concern
about the 12 mini and that is the
battery life
first off let's compare the milliamp
hours of the batteries we have about
1800 on the se
about 2200 on the 12 mini so 400 more
and then stepping up to the regular 12
20 800 so
600 milliamp hours more now obviously we
haven't been able to test these
just yet we'll talk about battery life
in our iphone 12 mini review
but i did watch a couple great
comparisons one from mr who's the boss
the other one from the tech chat and the
iphone se will get you
about four hours of screen on time maybe
five if you don't use it as hard
whereas the 12 mini it looks to have
about an hour to an hour and a half
better screen on time than the se and
then the same thing goes when you
upgrade to the iphone 12
that one looks out of about an hour hour
and a half more than the 12 mini
so if you're a power user i definitely
would not buy the iphone se
the battery is its weakest point the 12
mini isn't great
but it's not bad surprisingly especially
if you don't do a lot of gaming
and heavy tasks whereas iphone 12 that's
clearly the winner
jumping into cameras the 12 and the 12
mini
thankfully have the same exact camera so
you don't miss out on
anything which is really awesome
and then comparing to the se well
obviously this one just has one camera
you're missing out on the ultra wide so
here's a comparison shot of the extra
width that you can get
now as far as the standard wide camera
we also have some massive
differences the 12 photos look great we
have night mode we have smart hdr 3 d
fusion where's the iphone se it has a
camera
from the iphone 8. the software has been
improved a little bit
but to be honest if you care about photo
quality
you definitely should be buying the 12
mini and as far as portrait shots both
of them
can do it with the rear cameras but the
se can not take it of regular objects
just of people now the really weird
thing is that with the front-facing
cameras
the iphone se can also take portrait
mode shots you guys see the comparison
right over here now of course you can
expect that with the 12 mini
because it does have all those extra
face id sensors but the se doesn't
and on other devices like the ipads
apple won't let you take portrait mode
shots
without having the face id sensor so
that's very weird
both of these phones have 12 megapixel
front facing cameras so here's a sample
you guys let me know which one looks
better as far as the video quality and
which one
sounds better in terms of microphones
now the 12 mini can shoot 4k
instead of only 1080p on the se and not
only that
the sc can only shoot at 30 frames per
second whereas
the 12 mini can shoot 4k 60 frames per
second
of course with that we have dolby vision
differences so we can
record hdr up to 30 frames per second so
in general if you care about video
once again the 12 mini is a much better
phone
and now let's talk about the prices and
then our final
verdict now the iphone se comes in at a
very low
399 dollars so 400 bucks gets you an
awesome performing
iphone now the 12 mini costs 6.99
700 bucks and then a hundred dollars
more for
the 12. so for that price difference is
it worth spending the extra money in
getting the 12 mini
personally i think for most of you guys
that are watching this video
it is you're getting a lot better camera
performance massively better camera
performance and you're getting that ola
display which looks so much better when
watching videos
it's full screen it's a much nicer
display and of course with that you're
also getting about an hour
to probably an hour and a half extra
screen on time as well
if you're somebody that's upgrading from
a really old phone and you don't really
care about phones that much
you just want something that's gonna
last for the next five years that's he's
going to do a good job but now that we
have the 12
mini for those of you guys that want a
small phone
i would go for that now how does it
compare to the regular 12
well as i mentioned in the beginning as
far as comfort in the hand
it's not that big of a difference not
like i expected
and you are taking a trade off both in
battery life
probably about an hour and a half maybe
even closer to two hours depending on
what you do
and the speaker quality and then the
nice larger screen
which is a lot more immersive for
watching video the last thing i want to
add
is gaming if you are a gamer i would
absolutely deal with the extra size
because when you're playing games the
regular 12 is so much more
immersive with that screen in fact i
enjoy the pro max
for that larger screen when you're
gaming and i feel like
with the 12 minutes tiny screen you're
gonna cover up so much of the ui with
your thumbs
it's just not gonna be anywhere near as
nice so i would spend the extra hundred
dollars
for those of you guys that are really
into media let me know your thoughts
down
in the comment section below how badly
do you want a tiny
phone are you gonna take the extra
trade-offs or are you just gonna go
with the 12 and if you really want the
se let me know
why make sure you guys click that circle
above if you guys want to see our full
review of the mini where we're gonna
investigate the charging performance
with mac safe amongst
a lot of other things and of course you
can help us reach 500 000 subs
before the end of this year click one of
those videos over there if you want to
see our ultimate charger test
or our 5g test this been max and i will
see you
in the next video